- We always like to wrap things up
with something that could
bring you some extra joy,
especially during the holidays.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(punchy intro music)
(audience applauds)
You may remember last year
we had some educators here
so obsessed with Christmas movies
they launched their very own
podcast, Deck the Hallmark.
It's awesome.
Every year, they watch dozens
and dozens of Hallmark holiday movies
and break them down from
differing viewpoints.
It's become wildly popular.
Now they've taken it a step further.
The two main hosts have a new kids book
I think every parent watching
will appreciate and recognize.
It's called "When's It
Gonna Be Christmas Again?!"
(audience laughs)
So I caught up with Bran
and Dan the other day.
So check this out.
- Hey.
- Hey, hey, hey.
- How's it going?
- What's up y'all?
So Bran, I'm gonna start with you.
So how's the holiday movie
viewing going this year?
- I'd be lying, Kelly,
if I didn't say it was
a little overwhelming.
Would it shock you to find out that
across all of the networks
there's 200 plus new Christmas movies
just for this holiday season?
It's overwhelming.
We're not covering all of them.
We're covering about 60 of
them, which I'm still proud of-
- Very proud of.
- 60 movies in two months is a lot.
We've brought on some extra
people to help us do that, but-
- That's a lot.
- There's a lot of Christmas movies
but a lot of fun to be had, for sure.
- Oh my. Yeah, that's a
Christmas movie a day, man.
Yeah. So Dan, tell us
about the new kids book.
- Yeah, it's called "When's
It Gonna Be Christmas Again?!"
And it basically takes you
through an entire year with
a family where the kids,
no matter what holiday
they're celebrating,
they always just ask, "When's
it gonna be Christmas again?"
And, you know,
it can be exhausting as a
parent to hear that all year,
but this book is about
taking a minute to stop
and to really see the joy in that.
I've got twin six-year-old boys
who are just the light of my life,
and they love Christmas.
And so, between those two and Brand,
they always ask "when's it
gonna be Christmas again?"
- Right.
- And so, this book was an opportunity and
the illustrations in the
book are inspired by my kids.
For us to see what it's like as parents,
where your perspective kind of shifts,
to say "Oh my goodness. This
opportunity to see the joy
in these kids' faces,
even when it's not time for
Christmas, is wonderful."
And so, you can have the spirit
of Christmas all year long
by looking through the lens of a child.
And so, we're really proud of the book
and that's what it's about.
(audience applauds)
- I love those guys and I'm
liking the post right now.
(bell dings)
So remember to check
out "Deck the Hallmark"
wherever you get your podcasts.
It's really good. You should check it out.
Now I'm about to do
something I know someone
in our audience will be liking.
That's because, usually
at this point in the hour,
we give our guest a
thousand dollars courtesy
of our season-long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
But today, someone here is getting it.
It's actually taped
below one of your seats,
so you might wanna take a look.
(drum roll plays)
Yeah.
Who wants it?
Yeah!
(congratulatory music)
(audience applauds)
What's your name?
- Megan.
- What do you think you're
gonna do with the money?
- Oh, you don't even know.
(Megan laughs)
- Oh, you're gonna do
fun things with it. Okay.
- I am, well...
I don't have a car and I just
lost part of a job yesterday,
so this is like the best gift ever.
(audience applauds)
- Wow.
- [Megan] Yeah.
- That's God looking out.
Alright, that's amazing.
- [Megan] So...
- [Kelly] Well, enjoy the holidays
and that thousand dollars at least.
That'll be fun.
- That will be fun.
- Well, happy holidays to you
and thank you so much to
all our guests this hour.
(audience applauds)
Anna Kendrick, Jordan L. Jones,
Duff Goldman, Sasha and Coco Jones.
Y'all have a wonderful day.
And if it's not, try and change it.